well it's time about two weeks ago I
posted a video telling Christians that
we should all be excited about
2025 none of the predictions the new
atheists made two decades ago came true
and people are noticing young people in
Great Britain are abandoning atheism all
of the main arguments of the dawa guys
have come crashing to the ground we
can't even get them to debate because
they have nothing to say the Avalanche
of apostasy is ex celerating and
Christianity which had been on the
decline for many years in the US has
been increasing for the past few years
seems like a good time to make some big
moves and big moves we shall make we
have multiple projects this year two of
the biggest projects I would consider
roughly equal in importance I had to
pick one to get started so we're
launching the Islamic dilemma
project what is the Islamic dilemma it's
an argument that a handful of us have
been using for a long time the argument
can be formulated in different ways the
simple version I usually use goes like
this the Quran affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of the Jewish
and Christian scriptures and yet the
Quran contradicts the Jewish and
Christian scriptures on basic doctrines
where does that leave us well there are
only two possibilities either Christians
and Jews have the inspired preserved
authoritative word of God or we don't
it's one or the other on the one hand if
we have the inspired preserved
authoritative word of God Islam is false
because Islam contradicts what we have
on basic doctrines on the other hand if
we don't have the inspired preserved
authoritative word of God it's Islam is
false because Islam affirms the
inspiration the preservation and the
authority of our scriptures so if we
have the word of God Islam is false if
we don't have the word of God Islam is
false either way Islam is false
therefore Islam is false you can go back
probably 15 years or more and find
presentations where I was saying that if
I could only change one thing in the
world of apologetics it would be getting
Christians and eventually Muslims to
understand what the Quran says about the
Bible because Christians don't know and
Muslims don't know if Christians knew
and Muslims knew it would change
everything every discussion between
Christians and Muslims would go very
differently if the Christian and the
Muslim were aware of the fact that the
muslim's book affirms the Christian book
as the inspired preserved authoritative
word of God there is a world of
difference between the way discussions
between Christians and Muslims go now
and how they would go if Christians and
Muslims were aware of the important fact
that the Quran affirms the
Bible over the past two years more and
more Christians have been catching on
and using this argument but they've been
using a simplified version of the
Islamic dilemma with only a couple of
Quran verses and Muslims have been
developing some smoke screens to dodge
the
issue but here's the
thing the Islamic dilemma is far far
more powerful and far more airtight than
Christians or Muslims realize it's as
airtight as arguments about Islam get if
Christians learn the argument in all its
Glory dawa is done it's cooked stick a
fork in it wouldn't 2025 be the perfect
year for Christians to really learn this
argument of course it would and that's
exactly what we're going to do so we've
got a big project lined up I've got a
private Community where we can develop
the argument without any distractions
anyone who wants to join the project is
welcome to join here's the plan over a
period of several months not sure how
long it's going to take yet but over a
period of several months a bunch of us
are going to read through the entire
Quran chapter by chapter and we're going
to find every verse in the Quran that
says anything about the previous
scriptures so I'll say something like
this week we're going through Surah 2
that's the longest chapter in the Quran
we'll all independently read Surah 2
jotting down every verse that refers to
the previous scriptures and then we'll
compare lists it's a little trickier
than you might think because the Quran
isn't terribly clear but we'll compare
lists and then those of us who make
content we'll figure out who's going to
make videos about which verses we'll
keep doing that until we finish going
through the entire Quran and when we're
done we'll put all of our videos
together into one long playlist that
will cover everything the Quran says
about the Bible and all possible
objections to the Islamic dilemma then
we'll make a nice study guide and focus
on popularizing the Islamic dilemma and
we'll challenge our Muslim friends to
respond then we'll expose their
responses because there is no legitimate
response we're about to get started
we'll have a bunch of people involved
Gian doc God logic Chris from Speakers
Corner Cameron berzi and others you
don't need to join the group that's
working on this project if you just want
to learn the argument we'll be posting
public videos as we go through the Quran
so everything will be made available to
you you can just wait until we start
posting videos and we'll provide
everything you
need but if you want to join the project
and go through the Quran with us you're
welcome to do do so there are a few
reasons you might want to join us one if
you've been wanting to read the entire
Quran but you never have and you want to
do it as part of a group of Christians
this is your chance it will be painful
this is a hard book to read but it might
be easier as part of a Group Two if you
want to tell your grandkids that you
were part of the group that formalized
and systematized and popularized the
Islamic dilemma you can be part of the
group three if you want to make sure
that you've actually read everything the
Quran says about this topic in context
you can do that with us you could do it
on your own but you can also do it as
part of the group reading the entire
Quran and finding all of these verses
does have an advantage it allows you to
pull rank in discussion with a Muslim
because you can say yes the Quran does
affirm the Bible I know because I've
read the entire Quran and gone through
every every single verse that talks
about the previous scriptures have you
done that and he hasn't he hasn't so you
can say since you never heard these
verses in your mosque let's go through
them F times now this is a private
Community it's the act 17 Community for
a while I've mainly been using it to
notify people through the app about what
I'm posting but I knew we'd be using it
for some big projects And So It Begins
the site is behind a paywall it's not
expensive it's mainly because most
people who might want to be a disruption
would not want to contribute financially
to the work of Christians who are
developing arguments against the Quran
so the pay wall keeps out some
distractions so we can focus on what
we're doing without getting derailed by
haters the link to join is in the
description box if you're joining the
group for this project will be starting
soon we just set up a tab for the
Islamic dilemma I've been told it will
take the app a few days to update but as
soon as the app updates I'll post a few
optional assignments to get warmed up on
this topic couple of videos and a
chapter of a book and once we're warmed
up we start cooking
[Music]